all right so we've we've just had a
really good roundup of the state of the
art of motion capture right now but I'm
gonna take just a little bit of time to
talk about what's coming up and it's
gonna be cool there are three different
things that we're gonna talk about that
aren't ready for primetime yet but
they're they're coming and they're
coming fast so first of all real-time
technology
second of all removing all the comments
of motion capture write all this dots
and helmet cameras in spandex suits
we're gonna see if we can't get rid of
that and then finally taking it all away
coming up with new ways of transferring
performances from one character to
another
now Digital Domain we've had a long
history of doing this we started with
the Curious Case of Benjamin Button we
did Tron we did Maleficent we just did
Beauty and the Beast and my colleague
Darren Hendler and I who's here is here
tonight he's going to come up and talk
with us during the discussion section
coming up he and I have over the last
year been saying you know we're getting
pretty good at this motion capture stuff
I wonder if we can do it in real time I
wonder if we can take an actor's
performance and transfer it onto a
digital character almost immediately and
so accurately that it's getting hard to
tell the difference between an actor and
their digital double now we're not the
only ones that they're doing this this
is active research and in fact the guys
over at Epic Games of course is this
sort of a gaming kind of thing as well
we combined with three lateral and cubic
motion are doing some cool things and so
I put this piece together here of some
of the latest research and the results
that people are giving hello I'm Simon
and I'm a digital human I was created by
an international team of artists and
engineers who wanted to challenge our
ideas of what a synthetic human
we start by capturing my face at the
highest pore level resolution we even
measure how the blood flows in my face
as I make different expressions we have
built a system that uses a variety of
machine learning techniques to figure
out exactly how the face moves and all
our yesterday's have lighted fools the
way to dusty death out out brief candle
[Laughter]
now just to be clear that last thing of
Andy Serkis both of those were digital
right the one on the left was a digital
version of Andy Serkis
and you'll notice when you saw me and
and the woman we weren't wearing dots on
her face and all of this was happening
in real time this is all due to some
really cool algorithms that we're
developing and also some advances in
computers right the graphics cards and
your computers are getting really
powerful nowadays and you can get that
kind of rendering in real time but also
can we can we get rid of all the markers
can we get rid of everything can we do
all that well the guys at Carnegie
Mellon are doing some amazing research
this is brand new it's really hot out of
the oven and you can see a grad student
here walking around being filmed buying
a single camera not wearing anything but
look at this we're figuring out how his
skeleton is moving how his face is
moving they're tracking his face and
even tracking the fingers with a single
camera so just think about this as we
transfer this on to movie sets we'll
just have a camera watching you and
we'll be able to replace you with
whatever we want to it's a it's a new
tool no markers no helmets no nothing we
could do it after the fact all right
those algorithms I'm talking about
it's basically machine learning you
can't have not heard this term of
five years it's what's powering Google
and Facebook and all these kind of
things Google is predicting your next
search using machine learning and we're
taking those same algorithms and putting
them into visual effects now they asked
me to tell you what machine learning was
in like two sentences and I'm not gonna
be able to do that but I have to tell
you a little bit about how it works so
think about how we've moved the face you
could think about doing this with
physics and you can figure out how blood
moves and how the muscles move and how
the skin moves on top of that and you
could do it with a whole bunch of
physics or you could capture the face
over and over again and all its possible
expressions like what I've been doing
right I've been sitting there going onto
the motion capture stage moving my face
all over the place and we take that data
and start teaching this algorithm we
basically say if these dots or this face
moves in this image we know that my face
should look like this and we do this for
the next image and my face should look
like this and we're teaching the
algorithm it really is learning
something and telling the computer how
to learn and if we do this enough where
enough is millions of times we keep
showing the algorithm pictures of me and
what my face should look like the
algorithm eventually adjusts so that it
can look at a arbitrary picture of me
and produce my face so that in a
nutshell is kind of what machine
learning is and it's coming to movies
and in fact the next thing I'm going to
show you is some of the coolest
technology out there you may have seen
some of this stuff this is this is
permeated around but we're starting to
look at this in terms of visual effects
and it is awesome it's just so cool so
I'm just gonna shut up and let you watch
and figure out what's going on in there
hello I'm Doug Rubble and I'm the
director of software Rd at digital thing
and right now we're experimenting with
some
really cool machine learning technology
what we're trying to do is take my image
and use it to control the face of
somebody else in real time so this is
this is really exciting awesome
so Doug and Darrin have asked me to
stand in front of a camera which I never
do and talk about something I have no
idea what to talk about I'm gonna talk
about the fires that are going on that
are super crazy like I drove my
motorcycle through the inferno it it was
nuts I I felt the heat on my jacket and
now my helmet smells like campfire so
that by the way is deer and handler on
the left hand side and and the crazy
thing about that is that's happening in
real time I'm pointing a camera at Vicky
and it's basically running with around
20 frames a second waited the 30 frames
a second we can do it and it's okay
and the setup for this was insane all I
did was ask Vicky and Darrin to stand in
front of a whiteboard and tell me a
story for two minutes just tell me
something make your face move for two
minutes and I filmed them then I sent it
off to the computer and use that data
right to train the computer when it sees
Vicky's face it now draws Darrin's face
in the same shape it's learned how to
look at Vicky and draw Darrin and when
it draws Darrin
it looks like Darrin it's it's it's
photo real there's nothing in between
there's no animators there's no
processing it's all happening real-time
so I know we're heading into the
discussion section hopefully I've given
you a little bit of stuff to discuss it
should be fun thank you very much